everyone on the internet was in love
with a group when asked if they enjoyed
it they'd say yes in a pinch Jim
Carrey's so funny Aaron Howard's a gem
and this holiday classic is perfect for
them yes the film seemed to make so many
people happy but the grump of channel
awesome found it all Kirby he hated the
grid every part of the movie
please don't ask why we're not sure how
this could be it could be his head
wasn't screwed on just right or perhaps
it could be that his shoes were too
tight
why would shoes affect how I feel about
something I don't get but the most
likely reason of all I should think is
the grump thought his brain was two
sizes too big
but whatever the reason you might want
to pick the crumbs bent hissed hi hey
take a flick staring down with a grumpy
grump frown he never got what pleased
all the people in town can't they see
that the crumb that's a remake is crap
I'd rather get my nuts caught in a law
rat trap PS that's gonna suck too
the jokes are atrocious the lines make
me weepy they scare up the Grimm's when
the Hoos are more creepy the originals
are classic no fixing required whoever
said this needs an update there's a big
fat fuck Alya pop cultural references
don't make a film work just makes you
look like a big dumb lazy ass jerk on
top of it gonna help me dr. Seuss PG PG
oh I see son was never child-friendly
and the more the crumb thought how this
movie could sting them all the grump the
heart I must stop this whole thing
Wi-Fi 11 damn years I put up with it now
I must stop Christmas from sucking but
huh
and then the crop got an idea
and all idea the Crump got a wonderful
idea I know what to do a grump said
sitting tall if I can't enjoy it oh well
ball a critique of this tinker is just
what they need I'll tell them the truth
my words must take heed so come on you
pansies let the bashing begin stop
smoking that hoo hash and let us dive in
so this world we discover takes place on
a flake I don't trust me I did a favor
for God's sake we see the who's in
Whoville our merry and bright many of
them you'll be seeing in your nightmares
tonight seriously these Hoos are freaky
as hell we're their mother's all
pregnant when they fell down that well
yeah there's nothing like a bit much
this is what Christmas is all about but
we see our main innocent and of course
her dad too this is Cindy Lou Who who is
no more than two well but we'll give him
a little leeway everyone getting a
bobbles doesn't lessen superfluous good
god kid does someone put your hair in a
blender it looks like the penis due from
the film Last Airbender I guess I could
use a little social interaction we then
see the Grinch the epitome of cruel and
yes to be fair that makeup is pretty
cool he looks just like the Grinch
despite the film's flaws but hey could
be worse it could have given him cat
claws I'm merely Doukas the Cure
improperly packaged my gear so as you
guess he hates Christmas to a tee and so
would I if I lived in this town
constantly for hope it looks dirty and
kind of polluted there's smog everywhere
and the colors are muted the white angle
makes things look strangely intense and
is it me or did someone rub Vaseline on
the lens what happened to you
and the constant camera movement has got
to be the worst there's more Dutch
angles here than in Battlefield Earth
this doesn't look magical it's ugly and
heinous
this isn't Christmas time it's Fear and
Loathing in Las Vegas but families we
know the who's at Christmas spirit in
check
well I do I refuse if I tried to keep up
with you Martha May oh no strike that
Vera's phony I went back isn't this
antic darling for you see these Hoos are
competitive and beyond materialistic a
town that just loves the spirit I guess
I was unrealistic for these who's are
corrupted and commercial to the max but
don't worry it's just a story are
threatened by talentless hacks folk at
night Betty and gee is it me or the
dhikr ratio is really bright if you have
some pie it's la those are Christmas
lights
oh really relating the brats in here it
sounds like something that came out of
Charlotte church's rear don't get me
wrong I'm sure she's trying her best but
we need the song like we needed one and
pull her Express it's pointless unneeded
and doesn't sound good Peterborough hey
speaking of things that should be
avoided if they could I give Kerry
credit this rule can't be easy to act in
green latex is probably not breezy hey
take cake take a cake double hate lows
entirely but yeah is he annoying I'm
sorry but it's true
is there a lot how much mugging a single
person can do what if it's a cash bar
I'll gather all right I'll go but I'll
be fashionably late just because you can
make faces doesn't mean that you should
can't you once say a line like a normal
person would didn't you take anything
from the great Boris Karloff you sound
like Sean Connery if his nostrils just
fell off those who's a hard appraisal
max but we get our worst and that's all
the battles only on account of villainy
little Cindy Lou wants to find out about
him if I was her I'd avoid him at every
single whim where did it come from
oh wait he came the way all whoo babies
come
ripped from the sky in their own palm
were sailors so we see the Grinch as a
small little baby that or perhaps a
young Gary Busey maybe as he grows up
even older and we see schools at hand
he looks like gizmo feels thrown in the
washer with a green crayon although I
hardly remember him I didn't have time
to socialize I was far too busy with my
studies we see a girl who likes him yes
she has a thing for green - you think
that's weird I know a chick who has a
thing for blue you don't have a chance
with her you're eight years old and you
have a beard so the Grinch was made fun
of for being so damn hairy boy who'd
have thought the guy from passions would
be more subtle than Jim Carrey so he
makes her a gift out of all that he's
saved but then he thinks that maybe he
should give himself a shave so he goes
ahead and shaves as Jimmy leaves a
couple Nicks and for some reason that
gets the class laughing all my kicks
is it me or are the Hoos just pool rebel
creatures they show us the true meaning
of Christmas in this feature even the
teacher is laughing dude what's up with
that it's not that funny lady she says
contrived as those brats so whatever the
reason is heart why shoes he stood
outside his cave hey team
wait a minute whatever reason cane are
you high they just told you the reason
you dumb stupid guy is because he was
marked all the way from the start what
did you just fall asleep in that part so
they look for a ringleader a
cheermeister they say to take on the
role just before Christmas Day the chair
leister's the one who deserves a back
slap or a toast and it goes to the soul
like Christmas who needs it most and I
believe that soul is his ring
so Cindy tells the Grinch in his Grinchy
Grinch layer dude did her parents ever
accompany her anywhere
how dare you and tap the glitches nah
the impetus the audacity they are never
gonna go another unmistakable sign of
the babies no your do so if you're a
strange person for one reason or another
who likes to watch men act like snart's
deform brother then the scenes for you
I'm so filled with glee and now please
never make eye contact with me my god
I came to invite you to be holiday
cheermeister so the Grinch heads on down
it'll be glad that he did because this
scene happens you know for kids so they
force him to party and have a good time
but one certain present starts to eat at
his mind a Weezer it appears to have
dampen his cheer it didn't make sense
then and it really doesn't here this
whole Christmas season it still feels go
back go back
mistletoe now pucker up and tessa nobile
me me me me me me me dr. Seuss would be
proud this is what he intended mistletoe
but for mom to get offended and Jim
Carrey's rains once again is in stock
can you believe he used to talk from his
ass I'm shocked
so the Grinch goes crazy and starts
attacking the folks okay that's a good
joke he takes all his antics and goes
all the way there's an explosion in the
Grinch who collected this Michael Bay
heart Lou I'm hurtin I don't hurt easily
so he didn't steal Christmas more
assassinated it when we finally get the
plot that the writers had procrastinated
he wants to steal Christmas after Santa
gets moving the wait the Santa's in this
movie that's a little confusing but no
matter he gets his stuff and starts to
head down to visit the sleeping who's in
their quiet little town
at the risk of sounding incredibly draw
don't wake him open no barrel roll so
this step is actually pretty close to
the book I know I guess someone actually
did take a look Santa Claus what are you
doing with her tree but you know that
old Grinch was so smart and so slick and
thankfully Cindy was as dumb as a brick
seeing ones Christmas really about
vengeance
I mean presents then he patted her head
and he got a rude ring and he sent her
to bed but hey she could still have some
fun with me how eat a liver with fava
beans and a nice Chianti
Sanna what don't predict the Grinch odds
seeing how the Grinch is someone she
knows but it folder in the book so I
guess we'll let it go but he was a seen
I simply cannot let fly it's when the
Grinch sees the mayor's house and needs
to drop by ah Martha if you ever kissed
a man who lost his tonsils twice no
silly
oh but it's an experience that I've
always loved you
really film really you had to go there
the Arrested Development guy kissing a
dogs derriere did your five-year-old
decide to start writing this part
kissing dogs anuses haha this is high
art no just to clarify this is the
Christmas classic you all love a dog's
ass a guy's lips pleasantly shoved have
you gone crazy or totally insane how can
this scene cause none of you pain what
the hell would Peter say for this little
canine no he'll as long as he's not
wearing a tanooki suit it's fine so as
the film promised he steals the holiday
which puts all the Hoos in alarming
dismay invite the Grinch destroy
Christmas you choose to listen to a
little not to be taken seriously girl it
takes them a while five minutes or more
to realize that Christmas doesn't come
from a store I'm glad he took our
presents you can't hurt Christmas mr.
mayor because it isn't about the they
get I don't need anything more for
Christmas than this right here my family
you know I kind of like the original
yeah I know big surprise but it made
sense that they already knew where
Christmas lies for nothing could dampen
it and that was uplifting here there's
blaming and yelling before they start
shifting the message is there but it
doesn't stand as tall and if you can't
remake it better why are we making at
all maybe Christmas perhaps
means a little bit more
Wow
way to ruin such a touching little scene
good God for a moment I almost saw
subtlety that's right keep yelling make
faces like a whore has lasted the whole
movie we can take a bit more
so gods in this movie well then I didn't
know does he say I am the creator of a
television show so with a smile from
Cindy and a pedo smile from him he
brings the gifts back in the town lets
him in he hands back the presents and
everyone is happy only one other thing
could make this ending more sappy my
heart belongs to someone else the girl
all grown up what's the date him now see
because once you've gone green there's
nothing in between so Christmas is as
high as anybody reaches and the Grinch
carve the Beast made from fresh roasted
speeches her watch the ghetto I knew too
late gather be mine
that's the film oh my god would it be
any longer I bet you're wondering what I
would do to make it any stronger well
maybe you could shorten it by an hour -
and maybe some bright colors for a
friendlier view a more subtle actor
might be anticipated and hey you know
what else why not make it animated yes
those are the changes that I would
insist oh wait we don't need to fucking
access the original was fine spend your
time watching that much better than is
horrifying crap in a hat it's downright
unpleasant unbearable unfunny nothing in
this movie seems colorful or sunny it's
not fun to look at it's not fun to watch
o earth did this classic get so goddamn
botched I really hate this movie and you
know what so should you I'm the
Nostalgia Critic I remember it so you
don't have two holes in the crumb a
perfect is it their finding right now
that this movie issue they're watching
right now I knew just what they'll do
the mouths will hang open for a moment
or two and then they'll try the genius
of you know now those are reactions that
I simply must we he went to the Commons
to take a look and see but the reactions
here Carter didn't seem very sad if
anything these reactions seemed rather
glad
well they still loved the movie from
beginning to end
there was no one to anger upset orphan
he didn't stop a people from liking it
they loved it somehow or other it was
still just has beloved and the grub
feeling like he's been horribly conned
set puzzling and puzzling what the
hell's going on mistletoe but they like
boobs be harassed they like single
pervert kiss a dog's ass he household of
a deep puzzled till his puzzler was
hollow then the crumb thought of
something he hadn't before just because
he hates something doesn't mean others
should he could share not force his
opinion like others would for its whole
are different outlooks that makes us
people grow and everyone is different
like every flake of snow for different
points of view could exist for a reason
to learn about one another
and to make each other
now I'm right they're wrong well fuck
you then
now pucker up and tessa nobile me me me
me me me me me me